you
well hey everybody uh glad to be back
hope everybody is well we have a second
moderator
with us today so i want to appreciate
them
so they are going to keep us on task
i believe we've thrown out the discord
server but yeah whole community
is getting larger but if you are new
here
thanks for joining us i am sam from
python basics and i do
a bi-weekly stream here with on free
code camp
uh they have been gracious enough to
allow me to take over their
channel for an hour or so every other
tuesday
i really enjoy doing this um
i should have looked i never remember
cardinal help me uh
is this 12 or is this uh 11.
i can't remember but we have been doing
streams for a while bo
uh he does a fantastic job uh
allowing me to do these streams and i
we have our own playlist so you can jump
over there if you
are really new saw some comments before
we got started today
but all right what we're going to be
doing today are some
actually real problems that i ran into
in my learning process 13th today is the
13th
video that excuse me stream that we have
done and
right after the streams are concluded
they go
uh they go back and are uh
stored and then they get kicked over to
the playlist and want to appreciate
quincy for allowing me
uh this wonderful opportunity to be with
you guys uh every so often so okay
second conversion so uh
epic time epoch time however you say it
uh time in the computing world
is uh tracked by seconds
the base baseline time is
uh january 1st 1970
actually something that's older than me
so but what
but then what you need to be aware of is
well what does that mean i have 10 000
seconds well let's actually build
something
that is going to allow us to
figure out how much time is actually
passed
i haven't actually checked do i have my
mic off or on
i didn't even check that because i muted
it earlier but we are all good
okay so we need to think about how in
the world
are we going to do this so first we need
to
get our header uh line going so we're
just going to take in
an x and do this so
for those of you who haven't thought
about this uh and
you're very fortunate i have because i
i would say i'm a uh a
a nerds nerd all right so anybody have
any clue how many seconds
are in a day anybody ever thought about
it
all right and that is absolutely fine
if you are a beginner everything that i
do is
thought of and the purpose of what i do
is if you have no clue
ever have you ever done a line of python
that's absolutely fine
my whole channel is dedicated to that so
down in the description below
is the link to my my personal
youtube channel python basics and uh
starts from the beginning and goes on
over 800 videos so all right
so we know there's 60 seconds in a
minute uh
60 minutes in an hour
24 hours in a day so there are 86
400 seconds in a day so
if we think about how in the world we're
gonna do this
correct we need to have buckets to
divide this
out and if
how would we go about maybe starting to
fill up these buckets
because we've we're going to have to
uh okay sorry
i was looking at some comments don't
know what the lag is
but um see we got a really substantial
number of people here today so i'm
actually kind of excited
all right um
so we need to fill up the largest bucket
we want to track so our first bucket is
going to be
days and then we're going to fill up any
leftover from there so what
what tools do we have at our disposal
to find out what is
leftover so we have
we have one way that we find
a remainder but then there's another way
to know when we fill up
a full bucket so we're actually going to
utilize
the floor division all right
so let's think about this so if i have
72 seconds
and i divide it by 60 so i want to know
how many minutes that is well that's 1.2
but the dilemma here is
all right so now i'm gonna take 1.2
and then i have a mathematical problem
so okay so then i'd want to multiply
this by
60 to then know that i have one minute
and 12 seconds
no we don't want to do that but if i go
through here and i use my floor division
oh okay so then
then i can go through and set this up
where are my notes sorry then i can set
this up
and maybe then know what i have
what i have left because then
i do this so then i do my modulo
ah-ha so now here are two
of our basic operators
that we've known and seen
that actually we are going to use
command line today we're going to toy
around with that
and find specific files that's going to
be something that we're going to have a
good time doing
all right
um
okay
uh all right so we need to get this
going so first we need to figure out
we need to fill up with our largest
bucket first right so we're going to
take
day equals
and we we know that we assign a variable
with the equal sign and we link that
information together so the first
the very first thing we're going to do
is we're going to take our 86
400. so if this fills up
one of these i have a full day
so let's
print we'll just go from here
oops
and i think i've talked spoken to this
oops we'll just do 86 400.
we'll just make this all right so i have
one day and before we get started we
want to
i want to lay out this format so it's
going to be
day and close this
out and as we go through we'll add to it
okay so
how many days we have one so what i'm
doing here is i'm not going to write all
of this at one time
i'm going to go through and
incrementally change this so all right
okay so we did over here where i get
so that was minutes so all right let's
take our
uh seconds
and we have 86 400 right
so then i'm going to take my seconds
divided by
86 400. and i get one
hmm okay so then if i
if i go if i change this
to let's see let's say
ninety thousand so i go seconds
floor division eight six four zero zero
still get one but i don't know
how many how many hours that is because
so i could go ninety thousand
minus eight six four hundred
okay i have thirty six hundred seconds
left over so then how many are
are in an hour
60 seconds in a minute so
okay hmm
but i want to make this a little bit
neater because i want this to be uniform
i didn't want this to be
how is this used well if you're tracking
time so uh if you're just joining us
what we're doing right now is a second
conversion so computers
uh typically uh
a windows and uh unix
track in seconds so seconds going by
so if you're having larger lengths of
time go by
in events you need to know how to
convert this over
you can use the time module to uh
to see the actual date and time that
that
epic time would be but if you need to
know the length of time
we kind of need to think through this
problem
all right so now i could do this
or i then make a new variable
where i come up here and i go hours
then make sure i'm going to do this
right
so then i go x
modulo 86400
then i do floor division on 3600 which
is
our seconds times our minutes and that's
how many seconds are in an hour so 86
86 400 seconds in a day
3600 seconds in an hour
so that's what i'm doing right here i'm
filling up my day bucket
if if i do so if i change this
to right here if i drop this down to 80
just 80 000
i will have zero days right
so let's keep this 86
4. so i have
i have one day but now let's chain let's
add hours so now
now i do fill up the day bucket first
because if you go in reverse you're
automatically
going to be overflowing the second
bucket we're going to do days
we're just starting with days we could
go weeks months however you want to
actually i guess days and weeks months
they vary all right so fill up the day
bucket
now we're going to fill up the
the uh
there we go oops and we need to get this
formatting right so now that we have
multiple
so we're going to go f and then
day and then
colon h
and if you do not know what i'm doing
right here is i'm doing string
formatting
so here are my placeholders and here are
my variables
all right let me see if i close this all
out
so now i have
let's see
86 000 now we need to make this a little
bit
larger actually let's get another one
seconds
let's do our 90 000 because this should
be
so now i have because there are
we found out that we have a remainder at
90 000 seconds
we have one day one hour
so look what we got filled up this
bucket
here's our mathematics
for our leftover after we fill this
bucket
then we come down here we stair step
it's kind of like nesting dolls if you
think about that if you've ever if you
guys have ever seen the
very cool awesome russian nesting dolls
smaller one inside a smaller one inside
a smaller one
excuse me smaller one inside a bigger
one
inside and it just stair steps down you
can take them all out and repackage them
very beautiful do we have anybody
did i call them right are they nesting
dolls there's probably a better way do
we have anybody in here from
from russia that could maybe educate or
correct that hopefully i did not offend
anybody
all right so we fill up our day bucket
fill up our hour bucket
now let's really see how well i did
let's
uh
let's change this to 91.
okay uh-oh so do i have some remainder
possibly probably so
so now now i have this new bucket right
here
that is going to have that is one
[Music]
ish maybe so if i do that
let's see okay so i have
this so i do have a remainder so let's
go back to floor division
and i think i just made a mistake
all right no that's right
all right so now we need to do minutes
and of course this is simple
uh then we go x
pull out how many
seconds are in an hour so i'm here
to here
now
we need to do our floor division on this
is re
really really simple so
but we are not boom
placeholder brackets
i don't see chat i should probably have
discord open
so
cardinal and jan janet and cardinal you
guys are doing a great job thank you
very much anything
anything super that i might be missing
let's see
all right
gotcha awesome yeah cardinal i'll leave
i'll leave you open
on uh discord so
if there's anything i'll just glance at
that
all right cool okay so
now now we're getting real real close
and i did not put minute inside our
placeholder
all right and we need to do blue
okay days hours minutes
okay ah this is actually
turning out to be pretty okay so we got
so apparently 91 000 seconds
is at least one day
one hour 16 minutes
so now let's try to get some really
uh let's see if we get some obscure so
90
1 1 2 1.
see what that is so now we have seconds
left and of course
this is a super easy one
so x modulo
all right
and placeholder let's clean this up a
little bit because
seconds
there we go oh so that has some remember
okay so if i go
and add
seconds i think this is one fourteen
thousand 108.
changes the format actually yeah this is
starting to do it
so what we do know is from before
of how to get this nice
and pretty in standardized
format oops not five of them
so if there we go
so what i'm doing right here is i'm
saying i want this variable in this
placeholder and i want
two digits i guess for the day i could
i might need
well we'll keep it standard zero two
then for hours of course there's two
digits for minutes there could be two
digits and for seconds there could be
two digits so the reason what the
zero is is if you'd like it to have a
zero in place
or two character places
use a placeholder with zeros
or have it be empty so that's that's
what we're doing right here
i kind of like the zeros
but that's my preference so all right
um that that is
that is that uh the f
the f in print um is the f
the f leading so string formatting
string formatting has evolved over time
throughout the python
world and this is the most recent
because you could do this let's
copy i'll show you one of the older ones
that you may have
possibly seen before so we get rid of
the
f string and you go to
format dot format
and then you place in d hour
minute seconds and i get rid of
the variable here you may have seen
it like this before so we'll we'll cover
both
did i get all the bam
there we go so i get the same result
just looks a little bit different
yes absolutely so this this is
um and then there's even a precursor to
the string formatting which was
uh very cumbersome
and not elegant so the process of this
and
this is just another one of the hundreds
of examples of why i love python so much
is it's constantly
innovating constantly becoming smoother
so what the argument was is
should we need to type all of this at
the end or is there possibly a way
to clean this up and this
to me oops
looks pretty darn clean because now all
i have to do is just add an f
in front of this instead of coming all
the way out here and saying hey
i know this is a string even though i'm
putting this in a string
and going from there but it's just f
string
so all right
let's see
oops all right so let's continue on
now we are going to oops that's not
where i wanted to go
uh next next next next next well i hope
everybody
is uh having a good time and getting
something out of this
i sure do truly enjoy python so if
you're just joining us in the past few
minutes we're
here for about 23. have about i had
about an hour time today so
uh i'm gonna try to squeeze all this in
but thank you for joining us today i am
sam from python basics and uh make sure
that you guys are supporting uh free
code camp
it's a wonderful organization uh they
allow me to come and stream
every other week i was doing weekly
streams but my schedule has gotten
a little hectic which is is nice
so still want to do these things because
i truly believe
everything that beau and uh
and quincy are are believing in so
okay now automating
the next one that we want to talk about
is automating file names so
what i ran into in a situation was i was
pulling down a
tremendous amount of data happened to be
stock data
and i don't know if we'll do that
screener here i don't know if there's a
big enough interest
on this channel so i'll probably send
out some feelers and see what you guys
think
so i was getting a tremendous amount of
data with
the with the grab that i did with the
api
and i was only going to be able to grab
so much
and then i was going to grab
all of those files that i had these
objects these
happen to be json objects that came back
and so i was going to save them pickle
them
because there's a process in python
to save variables to files because
or as files as a file object so it
dawned on me that i could go and
save these but then i said do i want to
sit there
and figure out how in the world i'm
gonna manually do this
well then it dawned on me that when you
click on a link to download a file
you get you get either the file name
or maybe even something after it like
the date
so that's what i did so the how i
handled this challenge
was i took
import time so time is a module
that is built in too i didn't even check
and see did i have this sized
oops that's too much we'll do that in a
little bit
so that is built in to python the core
developers
have put this in for us and
let's just look at this wonderful handy
little tool right where is it
not good at my alphabet sometimes
boom so time
dot asc time actually
we're not going to skip a step we're
going to use our help so if you don't
know what the help function is
it is your best friend same thing with
der
so der comes from the command line
we're actually going to touch on that a
little bit so when i run dir
don't pass an object into it i get
everything that is downloaded in any
objects
and variables that are live at this time
and so then if i pass it
an object it is going to give me
all of the tools that go along with it
methods variables
attributes and
any functions now then if you want to
delve
deeper you use the help function and
the information that is associated with
that
whatever object you pass you then will
get everything
ac time so i wrap this up okay let's
slide this over a little bit aha
convert a time tuple to a string
boom so this is what dawned on me so
as i'm going through and grabbing these
files
i can literally sit here and catalog and
then it really just expanded upon itself
so then i now have a file digital record
of all of these requests that i make
and i have this handy little tool right
here now
we're going to run across a couple of
problems that we're going to have
but we know how to fix them so if you
haven't heard me say it on this channel
the purpose of everything that i like to
do is i like to give you guys
tools for your toolbox and make sure
that you guys fill them up
so that when you run into a problem
you're just not walking around with a
hammer going i know how to do this and
i'm going to beat it over the head no
we're going to expand your all the
skills that you have
so that when you run across something
you will be able to
revert back to it uh and one more thing
so i've gotten pretty good at saving
this
shell and and then uploading it
over to github so if you've not clicked
over
and uh subscribed to my channel and you
can just watch one of the
recent videos i tried to go back and put
it in as many of the old videos but it
is
standard and you go to my github
there's a rolling script that that is
the free codecamp
dot py file and then everything that
we've done over here in the shell
is its own folder excuse me it's its own
file with the date of today or the day
of the lesson okay that being said
let's get going on how in the world to
do this
so here we go slide that down some
so we need to import time
all right then so let's get
let's start with just f file fname
equals time dot
ac time
so then f name
so here we go aha so i have
this this information right here
but i will tell you in the windows world
that we need to fix these spaces
and these colons right here so let's do
that
so and we'll we'll stay we'll stay
uniform
to what my real problem was so then
we're going to
then i can
sit right here now if you do not know
let's let's touch on this
who knows how to change something in
a string
so now that i have so i have my dir
so strings are immutable
but i have
i have a handy tool
that and let's try let's see if i can do
my alphabet again
replace so has anybody seen the replace
method
so we need to do this
okay
all right you could do regex but we're
not we're not getting
we're not gonna go int or
string okay uh int would convert
a string that isn't that is an integer
to an integer and if i had an int
here i would wrap this
to convert that to a string now what
we're going to do is
we're going to look at help dot str
dot replace
okay self return a copy ah
so this is an important word return a
copy all occurrences
of substring old replacement by new so
old new okay
so if i go name let's try it over here
oops
name underscore or f name underscore dot
replace
and i know i have a problem with
a blank and i'm going to replace it with
an underscore
to solve all my problems and all my
worries cool
so now here i am now i want to see who
was paying attention
all right so why didn't that work
return a copy so this is not
in place or return none so this
is this is create so i need to come up
here
and i can literally so actually we're
just going to do this
like this
equals f.name
dot replace
okay see
okay all right
c has changed the original it hasn't
changed the original
exactly all right what's the quick
question
so what this does is this is creating
something new so if i were to
change this to underscore two
and run this so i have here
print
print file name
and print file underscore name
underscore two
i have i have my original and then this
makes a copy this returns
this does not change in place it does
not affect
the original at all
okay yes the live streams are available
later and you are able to re-watch them
and go to
the playlist and watch all 12
videos at one time and if there's
anything
there's anything in here that you just
need more of
over on my channel is a breakdown i have
extra
i have micro videos and i like that term
so much because
one of my subscribers came up with it
i'm not creative enough to do that
so what we're actually going to do is
i'm going to do this we're actually
going to come up here
and merge and merge and do these
on the same line so i'm going to show
you this right here
so i don't need this and we're going to
do
replace
with underscore so now
we just don't even really have to worry
about this so this happens
all at one time so i'm creating a string
object i'm going out
i'm saying i'm telling my computer to
hey grab me
grab me this um
grab me this time this time stream
object with the date
and then i need i have an issue
i want you to throw this
into uh
i want you to change this right here now
there's a little little trick right here
that we do have a problem
so i commented that we are going to be
making a pickle object
we're going to be pickling these files
and we can talk about that at a later
time i don't think we'll
get into this so i need to add an
extension right now because this is a
file name right
so i'm going to need to know where to
put it
so i got my oops
plus because i can concatenate
p k l close that out run this again
oops and
[Music]
where am i ah
saw it type thought i changed it typed
it exactly back the way i had it
so now i have this
wonderful file name right here now i do
have one little problem
windows does not like that
file name equals file
name dot replace
and i'm going to replace my colon
with a i can't remember what i replaced
it with
ah another underscore i always like
underscores
i don't like dashes don't know why i
wish i had a good
reason why i didn't like why i don't
like dashes so now
so now i have a this huge section
i will have all these files
yep i just got the colons great question
thank you
okay
all right so now i have
all of the files that i'm going to have
later now
you could set this up right now
and be storing these files and knowing
which ones to go and grab
if you have a moment and you're just
going to be grabbing these files
these json objects turning them into
files pickling them and coming right
back
now now let's say time has gone by
you did not same save all of these file
names
but you know that you have
all of these pickle files that are out
there
these pkl files and you want to go
to your
computer your directory your um
your folders and find all of them
so now now we're going to look at the
command line a little bit
and because this is where this is where
python
actually has this so we're gonna we're
gonna delve into
dur a little bit in the command line so
all i did was type dir
dir directory so now i want to show you
this
so you can actually go in so if i type
star.star
what i'm telling windows
is i want all of the files no matter
what it is the dot in any
any type of text after i get it
so now watch this so der
star dot i remember when i was first
learning computers a long time ago
you might need you might need
all of the exact files the
so now what i did is i typed star
dot exe all of the exe files
so now in this folder this folder right
here
windows will now spit out all
only only but all of the files that end
so if i were to go d i r
a or a star dot
star i get all of the files that start
with an a
capital and and lower case so now the
reason i
show you that to show you this
because now we are going to
um now what we're going to do
is we're going to learn about a very
cool
a very cool um
module called glob
i wish i knew the story behind why it's
called glob
but we're just gonna do what we do oops
helps if i do glob cra glob
a globba okay
because let's do let's run help
on glob
okay we got path file names glob
path return list ooh
this looks promising help
glob glob
huh turn a list of paths
paths or file names okay path is how to
get to the
information that took me forever to
realize so if you see
path that's not just path to the
directory
it's the path to the information the
file
the path all right
so now literally
it's going to be just like so where am i
so now we're going to let's combat this
out
import glob then i'm going to go files
equals glob dot
glob and i want all my so i've i've done
this
i've been pulling all this data for a
month and i'm going to throw it in a
data frame which
we'll be building to that and we'll deal
with pandas i love pandas i
uh numpy pandas
beautiful soup these are all the things
that we'll get to but
i don't ever want you guys to be afraid
we will do these
in little baby steps
um how do you eat and i i love all these
how do you eat an elephant one bite at a
time
how do you move a mountain one spoonful
at a time
all of these things are centuries older
than i
but just put one foot in front of the
other and then there's the famous disney
movie that i love to quote
just keep swimming just keep swimming
just keep swimming just
one day more
alright so now now that i have
this right here so now i'm going to
print files so i literally have said
glob.glub
pull this in and here are all of my
pickle files that i have so far to date
and in this in this folder i guess i
thought there were more in this folder
and
okay sorry i was looking at it all right
so now that so then i can go through
here
and grab all these files pull these in
and we'll do
that when we get going on our
an api well actually that's what i think
we're getting close to
sorry i thought i saw somebody pull up
getting close to if there's enough
interest because i don't know how
this would be too specific but i'm
actually kicking around the idea
of teaching you guys uh or making doing
a
doing a uh stream on uh
the ameritrade api for stock screeners
because that's actually
basically what i other than teaching
that's that's what i do
um is that i pull down stock data
and look at it and manipulate it and go
from there
so powershell without downloading python
yeah apis are fantastic especially i
mean it's a souped-up it's a souped-up
uh
module that somebody else wrote so all
right let's see let's see let's see
all right so we need to
let's see where else are we we got 16
minutes
all right we need to look at something
so here's a great here's a great thing
to think about
all of these things that i have you guys
do especially especially this
and especially what was it two weeks ago
with
our random password generator there's a
way to clean that up and have that be
much faster
but it's to get you everybody to think
because
i was such a one directional thinker and
one directional problem solver
but when i started programming it just
opened my eyes
of how and i really loved challenges
where
i would write a program and when i was
first writing them they were
horrible they were so lengthy well i
think i showed you guys my first attempt
at solving a um
the uh oh my goodness prime numbers
how if if a number was a prime number or
not it was it was
horrid it was absolutely horrid and then
i just made it
smaller and smaller and smaller and that
that's the point
get it to work it's going to be ugly
it's fine if it works
fine then go from there so
now the next one we're going to do is
we're going to think about
if we have a list uh
let's see x x
equals 1 43
5. 27
um 19 and
we have four in there okay now
if i say find the largest and smallest
well my goodness we can go to help
and here's the awesome thing you type in
built in hiltons
options wow cannot spell today sorry
guys
is it built-ins
ah yeah built-ins
oh my goodness there we go
so i have all of these
functions that are already
here for me so i have
max okay built-in function max
you get a list of arguments single uh
iterable okay then men okay
so i'm sitting here so if i say find the
largest or the smallest
this is this is just i mean this is a
joke right
so i take x
and then min
so i go from there it's 43 and one ooh
all right all right so now
what happens if i say
uh all right find me the second
largest and the second smallest
oh oh okay so that's
that's a different problem so now i
gotta
i gotta put my little thinking cap on
and how in the world would i do that
okay
well wait a second i have another
so i want the largest and the smallest
and only if i could have them on the
ends sorted so now
return a list okay
return a list so we learned just last
time that return
means it creates
yeah cardinal if they're if they're
they're distracting and jan
if they're distracting other people just
uh
look this free code camp is a wonderful
opportunity
we're going to keep this python centric
and programming there are people here
who are
dying to learn something new want to
better themselves
if you're not here to do that this just
may not be the place for you
so i'm spending my time doing this we
have two awesome moderators
spending time keeping this in line
so we're going to be mature and we're
going to be respectful of everybody's
time
so guys if they're doing anything uh
that's not
productive just kick them thank you very
much all right
so now if there was a way for us to
have this in a structure aha so
sorted returns something
so bam
but since it returned
it did not change so now
and we know from indexing so if i want
this one
and this one i know from indexing
it will always be if it's the second
largest or second smallest
however we want to do this and then also
we have
we learned about key a while ago with
our
sorting uh sorting our horse races
finding our finding our fastest sorting
our list of lists
we found our 20 25 bingo
second max awesome i love that
i think that's philippe philippe is
exactly correct for the second largest
we can index forward and we can index
backwards
remember when i found out i loved about
indexing
and i just thought it was so cool so
python is a zero indexing
uh language so zero one oops
sorry one two three four
five and to be consistent so you don't
have any repeatability
negative one negative two negative three
because we're already utilizing
zero we already have that set up so it
can't be this can't be zero
because this is zero so to differentiate
to then basically if you want to think
about it it loops around and i never
thought about it until
about three years ago when i was
explaining it to a young person
and they were grilling me on how it came
to be
so you can literally loop around and
just go
from here all the way around so five
four three two one zero
negative one negative two negative three
negative four negative five negative six
there so if i want to then
print second
and do that in strong second
our gist
to second largest negative one
and print second
smallest
x one
bam now
and all right so something
oh negative 2.
got ahead of myself there we go now
let's look at
if i were to changed uh
sorted dot reverse i want you to look
right here this is important about
sorted
reverse defaults to false
so it's just going to go in ascending
order
does it say there it is an ascending
order
let's just say you think about things
largest to smallest
so we change reverse
to true
so now this is this is flipped around
smallest
largest just like so boom
okay uh
yeah here's just a nice little mental
challenge because we're at
53 minutes let's let's just
yeah let's just go ahead and do this one
it's very cool
so ran across this little puzzle
a while ago so it's called random walk
so you're you're to a meeting early
and you have you're going to be given a
certain number
well we can do we can do this two ways
we'll have a more advanced and then a
basic
so you're going to be given
um a number
of units and that's how long it takes
to go around the blocks so you go
down a block up a block so if you're
given
uh it takes an equal amount of time so
you're given east
west south and north and
we'll talk about the units in a minute
and if you end up
you only if if you end up back at the
same place
it's true if not it's false
so how in the world can you tell so all
right let me say that again because i
fumbled around so i apologize
so if i give you north south east and
west on a city block
you will end up back in the same spot
because you will let's open up paint
make sure this is centered so
wow that is horrible
all right so then
if you start here
you start here let's get a larger
yeah and then you go north
east south west
you end up back where you started so
how would you be able to do this
so there are of course a perfect example
of a way to solve
this problem but here's just another way
for you to think about
a problem and how would you solve it
so let's get this up and running
so the first the first way that i did
this the first time i tried this
challenge
actually let's kind of talk about this
for a minute so i had a question posted
i had a
comment posted on one of my
videos and i identified with this
because this is exactly what i did i
would read
and i would read a question or i'd
follow along it would make sense
makes sense makes sense makes sense and
then i would be given a question
very similar to it but i could not get
it i would
it would just i'd go i don't know how to
start
and that was how i was in school i was
not a very good student everything that
i know in python
it's all self self-taught aha
i love that if east equals west and
north equals south then true
that is a wonderful solution that is
exactly
that's actually where i stumbled across
later so what i actually did my first
attempt
that that was one of my later attempts
what my first
what my first one was and i will just
show you this and then we'll and then
we'll talk
here i'll bring this over
because i need to go in a few minutes
but i will just paste this and you guys
and we can look at it free code camp
so i started to just go back and redo
code
so i would start with the absolute
basics
then rewrite oops
then rewrite the code again so i'd
already solved it
then i would just rewrite it again and
again and again until it be
until i could repeat it on my own and i
understood it
so you have comprehension you have
understand comprehension and then repeat
that's what i found out so if you're
reading if you're watching this and it
makes perfect sense
and then we turn this off after we're
done
and you just and then you see a problem
and you just
don't get it you're not alone
okay you're not that's that's why i
started this channel that's why
um streaming on free code camp
that's why i started a discord server
you
i i was alone i did this all i was i was
sitting here
all alone tried books tried numerous
channels pieced all this stuff together
started teaching at my kids schools
and then this cemented and then i found
out what i could do with python
and merge the two things that i love and
now that's what i do
so if you are watching these videos
watching today
and you have seen these before and you
go i get it but then once i stop
once the video stops i stop getting it
that's
normal write something you understand
repeat it repeat it repeat it
and then venture out you're not suppose
this
this is weird this is literally another
language now there are some of you on
here can speak multiple languages
i only know english and i can read
python
that's it this is literally another
language this is actually a formal
language it's very strict
speech is informal that's a little nerdy
thing that i've read
all of the studying so all right all
right so this is
this was my first instinct so here's the
one with actually
the timed walk that i did so i actually
thought about it about coordinates
and this is how cumbersome this was
so if the if the length of time and the
walk
didn't match of course they weren't back
in time
all right so then i started assigning
values
to north so north north was one
and i think i gave east positive so
north and east were positive
and west and south were negative so if
you went
if you went to the east one and you came
back west one
so you'd be zero and then same thing so
it didn't matter how many
so if you walked east four times and as
long as you walked west four times
you're going to end back back at the
point same thing with north north and
south
so this is where i did is i did my
my coordinates up and down and up and
down and then i go well
that is that's really not pretty
that is really not pretty and then
this is what was posed to me so you're
given a list of the directions north
south east and west
and i was like and i learned about
counting with
so now let's see to do
put this in so walk
walk is a list right so then
i run dir on walk which is
a list object and python will tell me
hey
if you if you don't know type this is
another awesome tool another built-in
so walk the list the type of object that
it is is a list
i can count so i can count
what is inside of it so how does it how
does it really work
so i go help dot walk or i can type list
count return number of occurrences
of value okay so i want to know how many
norths are in my list how many souths
are in my list
and i created variables north south east
and west
so that i did how long is the walk so
if basically if north
and south are equal to each other
equivalent
in python two equal signs is actually
the equivalency test
and and is a very good keyword so we
need to go here we need to talk about
this
and then i'll start wrapping this up
word oop
let's go to the help prompt
because i do not like this is i had i
have very few complaints about python i
do not like that you cannot run help
on uh a keyword but you can get to the
keyword
through the health help prompt so i type
in and
here we go so i have a it's a boolean
operation
and you're going to test if two things
are true
so let's see what this does so true
of course is true does true
equal true it's true
so true and
true true true and
false so they both they both have to be
true for and now there's an or just one
of them has to be
so i did north is north equivalent to
south
and east and west equivalent to each
other
and in this instance i did the one about
time
are is the length of time the length of
the list the length of the walk
so all of these if all of these are true
then bam i ended up back at my original
location
in my allotted amount of time
okay there we go and i gotta run guys
but absolutely
uh amazing stream today
thank you to jan and cardinal our two
awesome moderators
uh jan has been i want to give
uh both jan and cardinal props uh jan
has been spreading the word for
the discord server cardinal is actually
the creator of our discord server so one
appreciate
um cardinal and just
i absolutely love this community i never
want you guys to feel alone
that was the original i didn't want you
to struggle with learning was
the original idea i wanted you to have a
place where you could find
every single concept in a video
that you can watch come back re-watch
however many times
you wouldn't have to dig through a very
elaborate video going where did i see
that where did i see that
another one other thing don't ever
delete any code don't throw away
anything don't
delete a file save it put in the cloud
don't
throw away anything so there we go guys
thank you so much for watching make sure
you're buying some uh
free code camp merch think you saw my
shirt earlier
uh wonderful organization they're doing
some fantastic work
truly appreciate getting to be here with
you guys uh
don't forget to click over to my channel
uh
subscribe there got videos five times a
week coming out have our discord server
so you're never alone somebody is always
on
somewhere so there we go guys as always
thanks for watching and we will see you
guys in two weeks
bye guys